hey guys it's Justine and I'm so excited
because today we are unboxing a brand
new product from Apple this is something
like you've never seen before it's
called the homepod
oh wait
and here they are the brand new second
generation homepod we have the midnight
and the classic white I don't know if
it's classic white but it's the same as
the other one so it's classic to me I'm
hyped about this because I love my home
pods I honestly when I say no joke I
have them in literally every single
possible room and crevice of my home and
office that I possibly could have a
homepod
I'm not joking so now the question is
who's getting replaced by the second gen
or do we just squeeze these in somewhere
else where there's not a homepod already
decisions decisions although I will say
some of my home pods especially the one
that I have in the bathroom because I'm
always doing my hair and makeup it's um
it has turned a a different shade of
white it's more a little tan now so
that's a personal problem all right
first up let's unbox the midnight we've
got some nice little tabs here
I don't even need a knife
or do I
I don't even think I could use a knife
if I need it if I wanted to
I tried
here it is okay I can already tell the
color is different I gotta look right
now I gotta see
well like slightly like a slight
different color and it looks like yeah
like a little bit darker maybe and like
a slight hint of like a blue little
undertone hello little friend
oh
okay this is the most exciting thing
about having this new generation is the
cable is actually detachable I was
concerned because there were some rumors
that it was detachable and then I read
some other articles that said that it
wasn't and I'm so glad that we can
officially confirm
not only smells good but the cable is
also detachable
oh that's so that makes me so happy okay
so inside of the box we have our cable
look at that thank you thank you thank
you thank you Apple oh this just makes
me so happy
oh yes we do not have stickers
stickers
are those stickers
oh they're no stickers oh no
we haven't everyone's gonna be okay
we're all gonna be okay so comparing the
two tops side by side the new homepod is
set in a little bit whereas this one is
completely flushed to the top you can
also see that they have the plus and
minus and that's visible which is
actually really exciting because before
you wouldn't actually be able to see
those until you activate a series so you
can just kind of come up very quickly to
turn up music or turn it down also the
entire top will light up now whereas the
other one just kind of was focused more
in the center so I am excited to see
what that looks like but that is also
kind of very similar to the homepod mini
that we have right here you can see that
also has the plus and minus visible and
the top is also recessed in just
slightly honestly this homepod mini is
so impressive it's so crazy how much
they've packed into this tiny tiny
little treat all right first home pod
has been unboxed let's check out the
white one
this is a very satisfying unboxing
experience
like look at this just wonderful
this white is
so white like it's so clean I don't even
want to hold up one of my old versions
next to this because I don't think that
it's that clean
also got the cable I'm not going to
disappoint Myself by looking for
stickers
oh look at you you look so nice
you look just like your friend but
slightly different here they are let's
get the white one and hold it up next to
it so I have two
let's see which one is cleaner like yeah
you can definitely tell this one needs
to be in my bathroom so that's all like
for like makeup it's not even that bad
well okay I mean when you compare it to
the brand new one I mean look at that
can you see the difference you can see
it came 4K now that the Run
but it's time to find a place for these
pods in my home
[Music]
oh
so here it is this is the new homepod
second generation which by first look
actually looks very similar to the first
gen so what really is new it has a very
similar body style but a slightly larger
touchscreen area that's more recessed
into the homepod I actually really
prefer this look over the original the
mesh looks almost the same as well but
it's supposedly more acoustically
transparent the new home plot is priced
at 299 while the original was 349 and
was sadly discontinued in April 2021.
now compared to the homepod mini which
is still such a surprisingly powerful
small little speaker you can get one of
those for 99 I do feel like this is such
an interesting move by Apple to
basically launch such a similar product
but with internal specs that technically
on paper don't seem like that much of an
upgrade but more on that in a second now
with that being said I love my homepod
so much and I use them absolutely every
single day in almost every room of my
home and my office it basically Powers
my smart home and the sound is so
amazing that I'm always listening to
music or audiobooks podcasts throughout
the house and I love that I can easily
move the sound with me from room to room
now let's take a little look inside here
and see what's actually in these things
now this is the high Excursion woofer
there's a four microphone array theme
forming array of five tweeters to direct
the sound down and out of the bottom of
the homepod to prevent unwanted table
Reflections the S7 chip for the advanced
computational audio internal bass EQ
microphone to actively measure the
internal pressure created by the
movement of the woofer all of this is
used to create room sensing to optimize
the location of wherever your homepod is
placed creating a stereo pair with your
home pods is one of my favorite things
you can use this for your Apple TV or
even if you just want to have a surround
sound experience but unfortunately if
you do have an old homepod and you do
get one of the new home pods you won't
be able to use the first and second gen
together as a stereo pair now like the
homepod mini this has a built-in sensor
that can detect temperature and humidity
of the room this can let you set up
different triggers to close blinds or
turn on a fan automatically when the
room reaches a certain temperature there
will also be an update later this spring
that will allow for sound recognition
for smoke and carbon monoxide alarms I
really love this feature because because
it will be able to alert you if an alarm
is going off at home and you're not
there because not all detectors are
smart home enabled so this can give you
an added peace of mind if yours isn't
one of the smart home connected devices
another big upgrade is this has built-in
support for matter which is a new smart
home standard that should make it much
easier to connect smart home devices to
whatever system you like we do actually
have this matter enabled plug here that
I can use to make any Outlet smart so
now more on why I said on paper the tech
specs of the new homepod is less than
what you would expect of a new device
the new homepod is using Bluetooth 5
when the old one used 5.3 it also only
has four microphones when the first had
six it's also using Wi-Fi 4 and the
first generation had five now comparing
the actual speakers they both have a
single large speaker facing upward and
the new homepod only has five smaller
tweeters arrayed along the bottom from
the previous had seven as for what's
powering it it has the S7 chip and a
64-bit dual core processor that is used
in the Apple Watch series 7 whereas the
original homepod use the A8 chip which
was first in the iPhone 6. now this
brings the question that I think
everyone is asking is how much of a
difference does this really make because
there are obvious enhancements with the
brand new homepod with the U1 matter
support and even the new temperature
sensors so like it just doesn't seem
like apple would release a product that
is worse off than the first one like it
just doesn't make any sense to me I
think that everything now is being
streamlined into a more compact package
which somehow surprisingly sounds even
better now what makes the homepod really
so effective at producing the best sound
is that the speakers have adaptive audio
they use those microphones to listen for
Echoes that allow it to map out the
location that it's in to optimize the
audio for that space so having these in
various locations in my home and office
it's automatically detecting and
optimizing for each room so now this is
all set up I can show you guys how this
actually works in my home I use Siri all
the time for pretty much everything let
me just give you guys a quick demo and
this is actually it already feels faster
than in the previous version he turn off
Main lights
did you hear that little chime that's
also something that is new because
before it would just do an action and
you wouldn't actually know if it was
done so that's kind of like a little
confirmation tone hey turn main lights
back on
okay
open kitchen slider
the kitchen slider is very slow
it's a very slow open
but it works I can use this with all of
the blinds in my house that I have their
electronic and it makes it so seamless
because I can just tell Siri what to do
or you could just go like this
but which one is more fun let's see what
it actually sounds like I'm going to try
to find a royalty-free track in my
library so that I don't get a copyright
strike so let's see what we can find
whoa okay
I'm gonna pause that for a second the
first thing that I noticed was that base
it's already it seems way better than
the previous version like that was
actually so crisp like I felt that in my
heart
whoa we're turning all the way up
[Music]
okay now I need to get the other one we
got I gotta find I gotta find my old one
where are you come here
this homepod after they discontinued it
like they were going on eBay for like
six to seven hundred dollars wild so now
I want to test out a little music
comparison to see what it sounds like
between the old and the new one so now
here we go we're gonna be playing on the
old homepod
[Music]
I don't know I don't know I don't really
have an answer for you I did feel like
this did have a little bit more bass but
the fact that this is using less
microphones less speakers and you're
getting potentially like a better sound
is still pretty impressive All Things
Considered but just listening to both of
them kind of side by side I'm honestly
not really sure I don't know it I can
promise you it does not sound worse does
it sound significantly better I feel
like they're pretty on par with each
other they both sound incredible so I
don't really know I this is this is
really difficult and you guys are
sitting there online watching this
through YouTube where you're already
getting reduced audio the music that
you're listening to is coming through my
lav microphone so it's really kind of a
hard demo but I think honestly just
looking at these two side by side even
though they do have a very similar look
this recessed LCD it makes it look more
refined now looking at this one it just
looks weird like it just doesn't look
like that should not be like that so
something that I never tried before I
didn't even know that you could do this
so this is kind of news to me as you can
have Siri play you ambient sounds so hey
play 30 minutes of ambient forest sounds
Forest now playing oh
a little ambient Forest
if I didn't know it I would think we
were outside in an ambient Forest jungle
hey play Miley Cyrus flowers
yourself for hours
are such a hit so I like to listen to a
lot of audiobooks I just finished Prince
Harry's book spare so what I like to do
is if I'm listening to it in the car so
here I am I just got in the house I come
into the kitchen I'm listening to this
now on my phone
I just need to bring this close to the
homepod
and it instantly those strings oh God
cutting me off therefore meant firing me
that's something that you couldn't do in
the previous version but this is
available in the homepod mini oh oh
something else that I like is intercom I
don't really use this that often but it
is really cool if you do have these in
various parts of your home and somebody
is upstairs or someone's downstairs or
if you want to call the kids for dinner
you can just have Siri use the intercom
feature and you can leave them voice
messages throughout the house history
intercom hey Justine wow I can't believe
how fast you are you made it all the way
from over there to all the way over here
so quick
hey Justine wow I can't believe how fast
you are you made it all the way from
over there to all the way over here so
quick I know I know hey Siri
intercom yeah I know I'm so fast I
should run in races more often I'm so
I'm so fast bye
oh I'm so fast I should run in races
more often I'm I'm so fast bye
I don't get out very much this is my
form of entertainment so one of the cool
things is you can set up a stereo pair
so I'm going to set up this home pod and
sync it with the other one over there I
will say that it's probably gonna drive
me crazy these are two different colors
but for the sake of this video These are
the two that I have that are brand new
so let's set this one up and get these
all synced up I move both of the home
pods into the same room so we're in the
entertainment room I'm gonna do a long
press here scroll down to our settings
and create stereo pair select both of
them
hit done there we go we've got our
stereo pair so now I'm going to pair
these with my Apple TV so I can enjoy
some incredible stereo pair surround
sound ah Sophia are you ready to begin
oh my God
[Music]
if you're wondering what I'm doing right
now I'm buying another black home pod
I'm not even joking
sounds so incredible
I'm so upset that I haven't done this
before like the only time that I've
really done this is for demos and tests
and I'm just like yeah I can listen to
this this audio through my TV speakers
which are I thought were really good
this just ruined everything this I'm so
so impressed but I cannot have one black
speaker and one white speaker and that I
cannot that cannot be thank you guys so
much for watching I hope you guys
enjoyed this video if you guys have any
other questions please leave them in the
comments below don't forget to like
comment and subscribe and be sure to hit
the Bell to be notified when I post new
videos I will see you guys in the next
one bye
foreign
[Music]